all right boys and girls
this is major league wiffle a league
that began in 2009 now has eight teams
50 players two of its stars are kyle
schultz the goat
and jimmy norp
the shohei ohtani of mlw
and look at some of this action fellas
how'd you like to try to hit that oh man
that is a lot of frustration right there
why are the guys swinging after it went
past them that's what i wanted well
we're about to find out
because they join us here in the studio
there's the shohei ohtani and here is
the goat guys thanks a lot for being
here we appreciate it uh and i'll be
honest i didn't know that for this many
years
there has been this is it's a
professional
wiffle league
it's been crazy it started in 2009 in my
front yard and we've just been playing
pickup whip ball for forever and then
over the years you know the word spread
within my community and youth baseball
organizations and before you know it we
have eight teams 50 players in a real
league going yeah that's that's
tremendous and you might be
interested to know that
this guy
idolized you
you're at that point now where you're
actual you're actually an idol yeah
that he can remember your entire career
and quote you back things you won't even
remember you're at that point now well
hey i love the fact that he's got the 28
on that was the tiger number
representing and the best thing about
the sign because my name was so long he
had to cram those last three little
letters
that's why i did that yeah
so you know let's not just stand here
uh let's let's see some of this action
and i think
first of all i have a question yeah how
do you guys generate so much spin on
that thing because i i have been trying
some grips right i know that velocity
plays a big role
so i i want you to take me through with
the ball yeah
for some of the grip and some of the the
breaks that they get because i was
trying it and i i have a pretty good
idea about the ball but this is
different jimmy did you ever picture
yourself giving a pitching tutorial to
the pedro martinez well this
that's why i'm so intrigued because i
saw the movement and something whoa yeah
if i could ever get a hold of you know a
little bit of movement like that or
maybe why would i make a comeback if you
asked me a couple years ago if i'd be
here teaching pedro martinez how to
pitch i just said you're nuts but you
know here i am so
the main grip and with ball everything
the holes are always on the right side
for a right-handed picture so you as a
righty hole's normally always on the
right side to get most pitches to move i
throw everything overhand no no spin no
no flick of the wrist except one pitch
was where you put your finger in the
ball and then you flick the wrist and
that's kind of how you get like the
baseball twelve six curve ball that
comes straight down but everything else
is just holes on the right side you just
gotta play around with it and you'll
figure it out how it moves what about
the air doesn't doesn't play any facts
on it because i was gripping this way
and i i generated one move and then i i
i was holding this way and i was
generating another one which is what i
guess the air rotates and comes into a
lefty and away from my right right so
that makes sense so just like you said
so like if i want to throw what we call
a riser it's kind of like the baseball
fastball but it goes straight up i throw
it with the whole like sidearm and with
the holes like this so the air comes in
and it blows the ball i i pretty much
understand that one right and then my
slider the holes face to the right side
so the whole the wind will blow it left
and then you just gotta mess around with
the holes so forget the the pitch inside
what about the hitting help us
how do we swing this thing
in with all you got to be all hands you
see guys in wiffle ball they take the
big stride the long hack it doesn't work
you gotta be really hands to the ball
short to the ball quick quick step yeah
shorts the ball that's just like the
thing
that might be because i want a big
stride guy i get it down here hopefully
that'll help look at that oh
would you like to pitch to your idol
here to get us started
all right kyle and granny here oh let's
go okay here we go all right let's go
curtis i'll be warming up right behind
you just in case
just in case you run into trouble in the
first inning
do we have insurance still with turner
and tbs just so we know you know i'm
retired now we have this
there's no crying in baseball oh man i
can stand anywhere in the box right
anywhere in the box all right normal
count yeah normal count
it's a real count
i'll get it down early
how about that love this is someone that
grew up watching me and this is how we
get ever since he took that picture when
he was eight you've been waiting for a
chance to plunk he's got to be a little
bit jittery
yeah yeah yeah what about you
duo
yeah yeah yeah we're off the plate hey
see i was a patient hitter up there it's
still passing over here we go now we're
in the hitters count real green light
oh yeah yeah can't get it
i'll
[Laughter]
here we go
actually i saw that hack a little bit
ahead of the
the ball i'd be nervous we got the
shadow here
and a shadow
i know if you're ready
hey jimmy j-roll
this guy's filthy oh
ej you know i'm smooth with a cliff i
know you
i know
i know you get them up get them up get
them
gonna go lefty off yeah
well you know and right on top of the
plate too
got to see one got to see one you've
seen it now all right
we got time we got time
welcome up jimbo just gotta go look at
the scouting report
see there's your twelve cents that was
your finger inside the ball yeah i can
see that i
i didn't even flinch come on can i see
that's a good take
he don't want none of this he don't want
none of jake bro
i'm doing ricky on them too
all right we still in it one two
change up maybe no you have to look
something
up
[Music]
there he goes shuffle two two two two
yeah
two and two you have to face guys
somebody
you
a little warm up
all right
let's forget outside just a bit outside
effectively just a little bit
all right go get it go get them pedro
go boys
spit on
[Music]
oh my god
hey no you're your turn let's go apple
taco
take pages
we're seeing it
seen that story one too many times
[Music]
get a little shimmy
[Music]
pedro
oh
[Music]
though hold on the one thing that really
sets it off they got the hats they got
the unis but they got official socks the
socks
has their own official socks that's
right folks
love it i gotta get up here i gotta get
a pair yeah that is beautiful thank you
awesome
amazing really enjoyed it thanks for
being here
game to entertain your family at home
too
now will you autograph a whiffle ball
for us absolutely perfect perfect that
is a wrap for the um
show presented by hyundai for pedro
jimmy and granny and for everybody out
there playing wiffle we'll see